pour sophie rainville merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france alors on vient de le
voir à vous avez décidé de vous livrer
dans une vidéo pourquoi ce choix
pourquoi parce que comme tous mes
collègues soignants voilà plusieurs
semaines qu'on crie à l'aide qu'on crie
au secours de toutes les façons qui soit
il y en a qui chantent il y en a qui
font des spectacles des photos des
textes et nous avons nous avons des
médecins qui crient au secours à l'aide
des soignants des infirmières et nous
avons le triste une fusion de triste
constat de ne pas être entendu comme
nous devrions être entendu je pense je
pense
pour bien comprendre est-ce que vous
pouvez nous raconter votre quotidien
dans quelles conditions vous travaillez
aujourd'hui alors dans lequel conditions
donc moi comme je suis infirmière
libérale c'est vrai que pour l'instant
par rapport à mes collègues hospitaliers
c'est différent et moi je suis dans le
gard dans une petite ville de ville où
le comique 19 commencent à arriver
donc voilà donc pour l'instant auprès de
mes patients un mois et ceux de mon
collègue elle n'avons pas encore de cas
de kobe 19 mais pour nous ça devient un
enfer de pourrir à la chasse aux
matériels
c'est un enfer parce que nous n'avons
pas de masques ffp2 haut quand nous en
avons x ont péri mais on aimerait en
avoir eu d'été non périmés tant qu'à
faire
nous n'avons pas de lunettes
nous n'avons pas de charlotte nous
n'avons pas d'école des surchaussures il
manque des solutions hydro-alcooliques
desprès désinfectant nous commençons à
avoir ça un petit peu aux comptes mais
c'est la ferme dont c'est à dire c'est
le maire de notre commune qui a racheté
des anciens masque périmés c
les dons d'entreprises qui nous donnent
des masques
voilà et c'est la chasse aux masques
donc c'est rationner nous avons 18
masques chirurgicaux
donc ce sont les tout petits masques
convoi blanc que nous avons ce sont des
masques cela nous devons l'échangé que
les quatre heures normalement vous
pensez bien qu'avec 18 masque pour la
semaine pour faire naître tournée est
soignée du patient j'ai justement
justement quelles sont vous dit sur ce
matériel est ce que vous avez des
informations sur une dame prochaine
réception de matériel verte à les
détourner
qu'est-ce qu'on vous répète nous si vous
voulez on dit toujours les masques
arrivent les masques arrive donc mais
simplement ça fait trois semaines qu'on
nous dit que ça arrive donc là
maintenant ça devient plus qu'urgent en
plus qu urgent il nous faut ce matériel
et une sauce matériel et je mets 10 pour
l'instant ça a été une organisation
locale en réseau dead de soutien et de
solidarité qui s'est surtout opérer ici
dans les premiers dans en ce moment
c'est ça qui se passe on
on a en a des masses parce que les
jambes et donne quoi voilà alors les
autres on entend bien effectivement
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
les inquiétudes le quotidien difficile
des infirmières qui sont en hôpital
quels sont les autres problématiques
vous en tant qu'infirmière libérales
auxquelles vous êtes confrontés c'est ça
c'est justement ce manque de matériel ce
matériel qu'on doit quand il est là qu
on doit acheter parce que nous devons
payer nos gants nos solutions
hydro-alcooliques
nous devrons payer tout ça alors que bon
normalement on pense que ça devrait nous
être fournie quoi au moins en tout cas
ne pas être aussi cher que ça voilà des
c'est toujours cette chasse à la chasse
aux matériels donc on reçoit des textos
des copains des faits
si 10 points soit super on va donner
1000 masques venez on va les repartir
donc on court à droite et à gauche
chercher de notre matériel en plafond
finement c'est pas non plus le but je
pense c'est pas non plus but alors en
tout en déplacement dans l'hôpital
militaire de campagne de mulhouse
c'était la semaine dernière le chef de
l'état emmanuel lacroix fait plusieurs
promesses d'investissements pour le
monde médical comment est ce que vous
avez reçu justement ses promesses j'ai
envie de dire où on y croit à chaque
fois mais qui jour on attend de ça on
est tous prendre en attente d'être
attendu il ya eu tellement de cri
d'alarmé de tous les professionnels de
la santé que on attend qu'ils jouent ces
masses relatant pour ce matériel mais je
veux dire on voit rien arriver ou pas
suffisamment ou pas suffisamment vite ou
au compte-gouttes c'est pas normal c'est
pas normal nous on bosse tous les jours
tous les jours à 5 heures on se lève on
va les jardins tournée et ouais elle et
on a la boule au ventre on va faire
notre boulot mon nabro vote parce que on
va bosser sans avoir de quoi lui nous
protéger et protéger nous soignons
également et tous les soigner et une
force matérielle c'est un matériel de
base de protection de base auquel nous
avons droit
merci sophie révil pour votre témoignage
je rappelle que vous êtes infirmière
libérale dans le gard